ich kann feststellen dass heute menschen
die sich in deutschland und in der
europäischen union impfen lassen wollen
keinen umständen bekommen das
offensichtlich nicht genügend impfstoff
zur verfügung steht ist es ja im ganzen
land daran gearbeitet worden impfzentren
aufzubauen
da sind teilweise 34 impfstraßen von
denen eine gerade mal den halben tag
geöffnet hat weil nicht genügend
impfstoff vorliegt ich glaube es macht
sinn im stoff gemeinsam auf europäischer
ebene zu beschaffen nur wenn da etwas
schief läuft dann darf eine falsch
verstandene europäische solidarität
nicht dazu führen dass kritik nicht auf
eine angesprochen wird und deswegen bin
ich sehr dafür dass dieser fall des in
versagens eine transnationale
europäische untersuchung nach sich zieht
vielleicht ist das elfte war der erste
fall für einen europäischen
untersuchungsausschuss wir müssen
herausfinden wer ist schuld was ist da
schiefgelaufen welche rolle hatte
übrigens die deutsche
ratspräsidentschaft deutschland hat ja
in der zweiten jahreshälfte 2020 die
ratspräsidentschaft in der europäischen
union inne gehabt was ist da besprochen
worden und warum haben wir jetzt diese
probleme wenn am ende die
mitgliedstaaten schuld sind dann müssen
dort politische konsequenzen gezogen
werden
das bedeutet eine umorganisation das
bedeutet auch dass man beim nächsten mal
dinge anders macht wenn die europäische
kommission schuld ist man muss man das
genauso adressieren den bürgerinnen und
bürgern ist es übrigens völlig egal ob
in berlin oder brüssel über die
impfstoff beschaffung entschieden wird
dem kommt es darauf an dass am ende die
eltern und großeltern jetzt mal geimpft
werden können
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren